and next to me a man needing no video
Christopher Hitchens best-selling author
Agent Provocateur who's a fearless
vlogger of all ridiculous things so we
couldn't have this panel without him how
do you explain how my kids people all
across the country and the world are
talking about this election that it has
become such a big event I'm never seeing
um James Baldwin remember Janesville
builder comrades will remember him and
maybe I'm here as the old guy for this
back um anyway I thought you were going
to very very very very very very
celebrated very brilliant gay African
American novelist of the 60s mainly
Giovanni's Room another country the fire
next time if Beale Street could talk all
his titles were brilliant too and I saw
him speak when I lived in London in the
60s that central hall Westminster the
biggest Hall in London huge rally for
civil rights and he said having made
this chilling brilliant speech he paused
he said to her all the English people
sitting there I said and just remember
something my brothers and my sisters
just you remember Richard Nixon is your
president too and everyone in the hall
went at the realization it was true and
everyone really around the world
secretly has always wanted one thing of
vote in American elections that's and
Obama is Sora is in a funny way sort of
promising than that another promise you
won't be able to keep among very many do
you agree with that list which part the
part about the rest of the world just
wants to vote and have a piece of our
action the Christopher is a young man
growing up wanted one thing to vote
which by the way we should say new
citizen voting this year for the first
time my fellow Americans wow I think
thank you
a purser candidate pulled out right
voted absentee and the guy was out
before my vote was counted but I don't
care however and I voted in do you see
where it doesn't count where we have
taxation without representation and he
was the worst welcome I could possibly
have had to this great Republic but I
was still full of irrational pride well
later The Daily Show and a lot of the
shows that everyone's involved with and
websites are really seemed to really be
bringing people into the process because
it's at their level is that fair or is
that just mainstream media blather well
I think mainstream media blather is why
there is The Daily Show on Bill Maher I
mean quite frankly watch mainstream
television and people who are hosting
these shows and part of the reason it
happened you sort of joke that we're
putting you guys out of business I would
say I wouldn't exist if it wasn't for
how ridiculous mainstream media has
become especially in telling what wait
oh well here's the classic thing that is
happening ah
when you watch television news on cable
especially um I sit in my living room
just as a citizen who writes jokes for a
living and I see the people asking the
same questions I ask myself of what I've
read in the paper so basically you have
Talking Heads from 8:00 in the morning
until 11 o'clock wondering aloud and you
should not get paid to wonder aloud on
television and that is what they do it's
like wow why does Obama still get
lecture to that preacher I don't know
that's what I'm asking why are you
asking it me back and then that's what
happens for this block of time so I
think that that is the number one
problem with all of it there's how
journalists and Emily Rec every ratchet
for whom I predict by the way a bright
future I was thinking how unsettle it
was and I can remember when Ron Reagan
had cancer in his bottom if you remember
this yes again makes me feel old
but it was a while ago there was and the
things steps had to be taken you can't
have a councillor King in the
presidential rear end so it came it was
just one the time of his reelection and
the Los Angeles Times published an
opinion poll so you decide do you think
Ronald Reagan's bottom cancer will a
return
B has gone into remission or C has been
completely cured you decide right you
decide this is Interac your version
count on the president's ass
yes that's exactly ok I've lived to see
it opinion polling has now become a
mockery of itself that's exactly it's
all designed to make people think that
they count or can count yeah neither
assumption is correct right and and I
and I think that that's right I think
that you know you guys give me a job
thank you thank you very much well since
Liz won't take any responsibility Ben
how about you is it all your fault
I mean you created Obama girl you know
whether there are plenty cable news
anchors out there that could have
fulfilled that role I mean what was your
plan originally to get a cable news
anchor to fulfill that role and they all
then I was gonna do it I didn't look in
the outfit now I mean you know there was
no grand master plan I love the idea
because I was in the office and I heard
some women talking about how this guy
they like him cuz his policies the next
one's talking about acuity was and at
the time I was watching a video by an
artist named Jojo and she had this like
ridiculous MTV video where she was
fawning over this guy so it wasn't like
any kind of plan at the time it was
wouldn't be funny to have a girl who's
obsessed with Barack Obama and you know
we actually put that video out a year
ago today and didn't think when we put
out that video we'd still be releasing
more Obama girl videos let alone that
Obama you know would have the nomination
pretty much secured but the the website
that we launched barely political calm
has been evolving over the last year and
initially when we put it out I did not
have you know a clear picture of what
would be today but now I think we have a
good idea of the type of things to work
online citizens sugar yes you're using
celebrities Lindsay Lohan that poor
Britney Spears to drag them in and get
them into politics well I think so yes I
think that entering into a political
discussion via the celebrity realm is a
really natural occurrence and it doesn't
mean that just because celebrities are
the welcome mat that once they get
inside the political discourse is
garbage I think that people need sort of
the stepping stone to get into it and
celebrity blog celebrity magazines have
trained people to follow politics I mean
we have learned how to create a cast of
characters among people
don't really know follow their every
move and I think that that translates to
politics in a way that's an incredible
parallel so of course people are taking
those skills and in going to websites 12
times a day to see what has Obama done
now and and if if someone makes them
laugh it's another way to sort of learn
about the candidate and interact with
the candidate and I think that it's a
really happy marriage their agenda do
you think that people are just looking
something to to connect to to be part of
a movement I yes they are and I just the
tag on to citizen sugar over here the
the point about following celebrities is
actually very important I turned on TMZ
which now has a television show which is
really frightening and they had a big
glass wall like like the Nash
equilibrium wall where they're doing
complex physics calculations Lohan's
eating for lunch at the ivy and I'm like
how can they're following people minute
by minute and yet the news people are
doing treating the same we're giving the
same respect to like weapons of mass
destruction or the Justice Department or
all these other interesting things so I
think there isn't an opening there that
you're tapping into which is really
interesting
you have people want to be a part of a
movement people want to follow something
I think what we try to do with the onion
is do what we've always done which try
to actually be America's finest news
source and do what we do politically and
satirically but journalistically at the
core we're riding in that journalistic
voice and that journalistic style you
see it in our videos in the radio
network and playing off of the polling
and the horse race mentality we did this
headline it was Obama Clinton McCain
combined to form nightmare ticket
because if there's all this hypothetical
like let's just jam them all together
and the slogan was like real change
solutions you can believe in finally for
America you can trust yeah something
like that like all the Brooks you
remember in taxi driver he's running the
senator Palantine campaign he's on the
third he said you delivered us these
buttons our slogan is we are the people
the buttons say we are the people are
you doing this much difference well we
won't pay for the buttons yeah we will
throw the buttons away but in fact the
joke is on him there isn't anything yeah
and that's probably the most intelligent
slogan I've seen the last 25 years
well I think you're all wrong I think
cable news is great not just because I
worked there for 24 25 years but the
truth is people learn a lot about
politics that way and it gives you guys
plenty of fodder Christopher help me out
here oh my god
no it's not go ahead and help her when
Sandra Bullock in Miss Congeniality so
she's got a run for Miss America is that
Oh knows that it's mary lou freebush
saying that she's in favor of world
peace
yeah digit of that FIDIC why do I care
why should I care what some celebrity
thinks about well I don't know why
candidates don't just start hanging out
with celebrities like if Barack about
what they do what their official I'm
talking about the Lindsay Lohan's who
get the most press just be with them
constantly we do it twice the airtime
now are just treatment centers like I
don't know today write that Obama was
emailing with Scarlett Johansson and
Scarlett Johansson talked about getting
the emails directly from him but I'm not
talking about Scarlett Jones I'm talking
about Britney one tragedy if you need a
last name you don't need to be on the
list right people um that people care
necessarily who celebrities are voting
for but I think that because celebrities
are introduced in our lives as
characters as people we maybe know more
about than our neighbors I think we have
an interest in who everyone is voting
for and we just happen to have Lindsay
Lohan as sort of this character in our
lives that maybe you know the girl next
door isn't so I don't think that we're
taking our political cues from them but
I think that there's sort of a natural
interest there let me bring it back to
the election and ask Christopher that
but I want to bring it back to what you
said about how great cable news is okay
because going I mean I guess I just feel
like when I'm getting information and I
don't know how all of you get your
information but I I can't remember the
last task let's have a story how many
people watch cable news every day and is
that your primary source of where you
get your information now we've been hold
on on the moderator list
oh the second question is when a new
most important question for all of you
should thank you for this when a new
story breaks do you run to your TV how
many run to your TV how many run to the
Internet how many went to the TV how
many went to the computer
oh this is what it's all about ladies
and gentlemen it's right here but you're
not breaking the story by the way
Rory's are breaking the internet they're
breaking friends'll all sorts of media
and then you guys slap a breaking news
thing on it when it broke already
you know when Anna Nicole Smith died the
news was no longer breaking it broke
she's dead that's it but and you went on
and on but like when I see for example
your ex Chris Matthews like this is my
ax be clear yeah ex host that's it
when I'm watching Chris Matthews and I'm
sure all of you saw on the internet or
Chris Matthews he interviewed a
right-wing kind of talk radio host and
they were talking about appeasement and
the right-wing talk lady host didn't
know what he was talking about and so
Chris Matthews beats up the guy and then
Chris Matthews goes on television and
talks about how we beat up this guy now
I was watching the segment because I was
actually myself because I'm not a
historical scholar was sort of wanted to
hear a conversation about appeasement
and what it meant why people were
exaggerating about it what Neville
Chamberlain actually did instead what I
got was a guy wasting my time me not
learning anything and then Chris
Matthews the next day on the news
patting himself on the back for beating
up a [ __ ] but we're ready I'm not
finished
this is a cable news show the question
is why is it good that Chris Matthews
producers didn't book a smart guy put a
dumb guy on and then let him blather on
and on I got nothing from it the only
person that gains something from it was
Chris Matthews patting himself on the
back well let that offensive let me just
defend him though because you're making
two points at the same time you can't do
that because you want authenticity you
want people to be real Chris Matthews is
real that's why he's successful he says
what he thinks you may not like it you
may not like the way the guest came on
the show he was a surrogate for the
campaign I wasn't there then I had
nothing to do a surrogate for the
campaign he's a talk show he was a
surrogate what you saying what you
saying though is important that the
whole cable TV business can be very
upsetting for anyone who has any
self-respect I mean
I was going know I was going to
I watched able to be only when they can
make me do it which is at the airport
where I can't not watch it so I got to
the airport because I was going to New
York for CNN they'd asked me on to
discuss a very serious subject I went
boy with oh it was but I got the I got
to National Airport as bud board the
plane and the headline didn't say fat
[ __ ] dies but it could as well have done
so the Nicole Smith vet which had
checked out well it's cruel of me to
take the ticket now and the hotel room
because I'm not going on TV tonight I
know that now I should really call and
say I'm not boarding the plane I thought
no screw that
I could use a night in New York at
someone else's expense I won't call them
so I get off the plane at the other end
and they said oh great so you're in the
car yeah well you know you're not coming
on I said I know that I'm going to be a
success and I'm gonna order a very big
dinner but this unless of course you'd
like to talk about any course no I
wouldn't yeah right and I mean you know
they run the risk of wearing out your
patient right and I think you know no
one's saying Chris Matthews isn't a nice
guy or a smart guy but at some point
whose responsibility is it when there's
guests that are on who have not been pre
interviewed clearly because Chris
Matthews as a smart guy because he
challenged him on it didn't the guy was
not there and what's not smart on the
issue and all Chris did was beat him up
instead of somebody getting a smart guy
on the show they're attending help me
out here I'm not gonna do that Tami I'm
sorry but I think I think I can add
another kind of example to this and why
people turn to the pop culture all the
satirical side for some of this coverage
mean all of us up here represent some
element of that it's because there's
something lacking in some of the
mainstream outlets
you know I saw CNN second I was actually
part of a scene in second they were
talking about Petraeus's testimony and
they spent maybe two and a half minutes
on Petraeus's testimony about five
minutes on campaign slogans and and the
font choices and the color and this is
the day 24 hours my friend it's like
that relative but that relative that
decision of twice as much time on logos
and color says something to the public
and it says something and I think with
the onion are very proud to say which is
II absolutely don't respect our readers
oh but we did say that we can't be open
about I think there's a message that you
get is the viewer or the reader from one
of those other outlets of absolute
disdain and it's something that we can
kind of have fun with but there's
something underneath of that which also
happens and it fills the void I think
too is you know when you see Chris on
Bill Maher and you see real debate in
real conversations because you can't
craft the joke unless you have some
information and so people are making a
point with information you might
disagree with the point but does spark
conversation it does spark dialogue but
his show went off ABC and he's on HBO a
premium channel I mean why is it that he
can't be on or anyone like Bill Maher be
on a network we've been talking about
cable but let's talk about a network
that was a network show there was
serious opinion issues people talked
about the show but exhaust I mean I'm
not talking about the political issue
but there's a reason because the
American people want reality they want
to see things act out that gets back to
my question for Christopher because it
people have posed this to us yes the
issue and the question is the Clinton
campaign and I I'm by the way I'm
wearing a Hillary Clinton yellow for you
the question is did the Clinton campaign
miss the boat in terms of for example
that the the videos they put up on
YouTube everyone you know put their
videos up what is it 7 out of steam 7
out of 16 candidates announced on
YouTube but the videos that they put up
were the absolute opposite of user
genna's that were just regular people
they were very slick very highly
produced someone said to me made-for-tv
movies do you think that helped it or
hurt the campaign I don't know why they
call it YouTube but all I know about
YouTube is that anyone who wants to see
me make an old speech again demented
very well the University of Chicago they
can go and do that and be induced to buy
my book it's a meet you it's for me I
don't know about you guys at all I but I
like this meet you bin ovation I've got
to say it's not the only thing the
Clinton campaign screwed up I think the
main thing that they've screwed up and I
really really rejoice in saying this is
that the person they thought was their
secret weapon the great campaigner the
great political genius the great
president revealed two crucial number of
people something that most of us already
knew because he's a raging psycho and
it's been very gratifying to see people
who could have caught up to that ten or
so years ago kept catching up to it now
when they think if was one if there was
only one reason why they lost it'll have
to be because of him and that pleases me
more than I can say I feel as if I'm
going to have orgasm in my trials you
think I do I've waited a long time
thanks what do you think that part of
that was on purpose and how short they
are too yes sorry do you know do you
think that Bill Clinton's perhaps
lackluster performance was too was there
any strategy Hulu as they say in front
the middle was a subconsciously he
wanted to lose do you think no no I
don't think so because it would mean
that he was in it some awful way back um
and I think he can't deny himself a
thing like that was lackluster I think
it was don't help himself anyway okay so
the lackluster it wasn't it was right it
was ugly was nasty it was is very much
there was audited
what it was was there was a camera
following them everywhere following
every candidate everywhere and every
person is you want to ask another
question about that since we're getting
so serious about the blogger the citizen
bloggers maybe I should ask citizen
sugar this the citizen blogger at
HuffPost who is the one that asked the
questions of President Clinton in his
angry response to the toponyms article
and Vanity Fair should she have
identified herself and asked every one
of the panel I'll start with you huh
interesting um well I think that the
perhaps is going to be my answer because
everyone has been empowered by the
internet to sort of be a journalist and
we need to start acting as though
everyone around us is a journalist
because we all have the capability of
publishing we all have the capability of
you know being in a fundraiser and
putting up the Obama bitter comment it's
going to happen so I think that maybe
those rules and mores of the traditional
media don't apply as much that we need
to have a sort of base understanding
that everything we
public there attend a I tend to agree
that that's the reality I think there's
a cost and a benefit to that and we're
in an awkward transition to the future
we know what the future is the future is
everything's live online all the time
Minority Report type of situation we
have access to anything you want any
form the politicians are now feeling the
brunt of that so everyone is a reporter
and they're trying to adjust and the
public is trying to adjust what happens
now everything shocks us oh my god Obama
said bitter oh my god McCain smiled like
oh these larger-than-life appearances
they won't shock us any more when that's
everyday it shocked us to see the
President on television it shocked us to
make a phone call across the globe but
now those are all normal behavior so I
think the reality that is live streaming
of everything is going to become more
normal and those communications people
who are up here earlier are going to
adapt their game to adjust to that sort
of new bed what I think is different
it's the fact that that this computer is
sitting on your desk
it's not a TV across we have your feet
up you get the kids running around the
dog there's 20 things in the way no
matter how big your screen is right but
when they're when you're looking at
someone having a meltdown and they're on
your computer and therefore interests it
feels different doesn't it it definitely
does I mean really to answer that
question in the previous one you know
typically online something has to have a
lot of shock value to really become part
of the conversation which is the reason
why candidates advertising which is
typically so slick and manufactured
isn't going to pop on YouTube because
what is it I'm saying I'm for changing
babies in the US and you know for us a
lot of what we're trying to do is figure
out ways to add something shocking in it
so the question about you know should
she have identified herself
well should she have ethically I'm not
really sure I'm not from the journalism
world but should she have if she wanted
to make a name from Hearst of herself
that does work because as she identified
herself her answer would have his answer
would have been I think what she did was
inappropriate but understand this as
opposed to you know calling her so a
Christopher said he said he'd go crazy
anyway right yeah well you know he's not
the mr. Clinton isn't very tightly
wrapped and he's full of hatred and
loathing and unreason and he can't
contain himself anymore it's become very
clear yeah Baker and anything said to a
voter at a public campaign rally is said
for the record by definition it wasn't
really doing it I wish I were talking
about Obama with them with Fowler
walking going and being at the Obama
private campaign are you talking about
there well we were talking about both
the comments at the privatize got a
Braille better break this too now we've
been doing Clinton for all this time no
no no by the way this is the new GLE
National Journal panel oh my god I
thought I was gonna be stripping sir
okay let's see let me just to finish it
okay there were two things look it all
together we lumped it all this into the
idea yes I thought I think that
everything is public in live all same as
what Cheney doesn't know the mic is on
right and calls my friend Adam climber
now so and so on and they don't realize
it's gonna be too bad but don't we want
them to be real I mean isn't the whole
point to learn who these people are when
we rather learn who they are
via this sort of medium then learn who
they are via their slickly produced yes
add and a list of bullet points on their
website as long as we're ready for it I
think and that's the part that turns me
a little bit is that I don't like we've
adjusted to being that side of a
candidate we still expect them to be
superhuman and super intelligent and
super articulate every single moment and
no one is but as a voters we expect that
of our candidates even though we know we
can't do it ourselves they're not us
they have more money to have more
education they've got more training and
management so I think we're all due for
a big bubble popping when we realize
like hey there fart smell - yeah but
what you said earlier was very good also
as as this happens more and more and you
see things like the president pulling at
a door that doesn't open in Moscow
things that people will also allow more
for it it'll be it will be less
surprising and it won't be it won't look
so brilliant to get it on the air either
so nuts there is a natural compass
correct which is that we have to cross
that chasm of awkwardness but 7 million
people watched all 37 minutes of Obama's
race speech on YouTube now
there's plenty of other media outlets
where it was watch seven million people
did that list I don't know about you but
I'd kill for that audience any night of
the week right I mean I think that and
ask anyone of them if they can quote two
words from it
no ask anyone if they did it at work
we'll ask anyone here how many did it
work no no okay then
ask anyone who didn't even watch all of
it what some of it if you can remember a
single phrase from it who's got a phrase
racist grandma right here Bob from well
from his granny right Oh
I mean there's a strategy behind how
they can you said it was the Gettysburg
Address
there's not a single memorable phrase in
it at all well except for dumping on
grandma anyway
well the Gettysburg Address memorable
immediately yes he did those people who
were there that day know that it was
going to be what it was
they blogged it right after yeah blog
archive yes there was a foot that was a
fight over the figuring out with
fourscore lack of the envelope on which
it was written and and but I think it
was it was recommended party because the
the opening speaker the curtain raising
speaker spoke for three hours so the
economy of the gettysburg address in
comparison recommended itself so have a
good warm-up act i think god but the
passage of time isn't going to make
people remember a word obama said of
philadelphia what are the most boring
speeches then why did i watch because
they want it to be true cuz they want to
be part of it well look this is a guy
who can make a speech accepting the
nomination or claiming it rather saying
this will be the moment people will look
back on as the time the oceans stop
rising so just by getting the delegate
count he's arrested the climate crisis i
mean i no one thinks it's funny except
me
this is a megalomaniac movie now the sea
will stop rising and that that'll do it
yeah someone from south dakota just cost
the super delegate i think there's an
assumption that seven or eight so that
you know then it must be viral and
everybody's watching it but you're
discounting the strategy that the Obama
team has that they email to a million
half people that they put it front and
center on their home page and so then on
YouTube within eight hours it's on
youtubes homepage and then everybody
sees Obama's race speech
and something that might not have been
sent around otherwise suddenly it's a
big quote-unquote viral video the day
but this idea of viral as it used to
exist of this is hot send us all your
friends is actually almost negligible
now that rarely rarely happens sometimes
Huck will be you know doing ad with
Chuck Norris it's you know so bizarre
that it actually you know crosses over
and that to me is a really interesting
you mary lou freebush anytime of yeah I
mean that's the interesting dynamic is
that like the the candidates who were on
the fringe like Mike Ravel you know and
Ron Paul were doing these really
interesting things online because they
were willing to take these chances and
the candidates like Clinton and and
Obama even when they tried to do
something that was a little bit
different you could tell it went through
like 15 filters before it actually hit
YouTube and and that's why you know
didn't do that much and part of the
reason the crush on Obama has you know
fifty million online views is because it
didn't have all those committees along
the way figuring out let's make sure we
don't offend anybody along the way so
you're saying it committees are wrong
too let's see cable news networks are
bad committees are wrong
what have we haven't talked about
Senator McCain and the Republicans today
we really should what about their
presence on the web and what's happening
to culture baratunde day you're right in
there because you're more honest than
CNN go well here's the fun part and
again I'll take it back to the
journalism of the onion is that while
Obama and Clinton were doing this horse
race dance and the network's that
everyone was obsessed with that we had a
good time being able to talk about
McCain in fact if you could queue up and
that video good idea let's show the
video now from our friends at the onion
he can get you to do anything you want
that little baratunde a vicious battle
yeah on this two side great so great
says it's a killer smile she does what
you say so I you know we don't like to
deconstruct what we do there so I won't
go too much behind but I think you see a
lot of the themes about McCain that are
out there and we've had an opportunity
to take that on while everyone else is
focused on this side of the room and
just to back him up we did run that
video with the headline the onion is the
only one talking about McCain right now
because it was in the midst of the
Democratic fight and they were the only
ones who were coming out and saying
these kinds of things and I think in
order to Lampoon a subject as well as
you
you have to really know it you can't be
funny without the knowledge and you also
can't get the joke without doing your
homework do you feel like you're in
competition with Colbert Jon Stewart
along the way how do you guys do it
that's like that's a really good
question we get that all the time and
the short answer is no we're kind of
comedy cousins because we're doing
something different they're really in
that daily news cycle of like this
happened five minutes ago here's our
response and we have a slightly longer
arc to that so it's a different it's on
a different spectrum of kind of the
satire and news game and what we try to
do is write things that'll last 10 or
even 20 years down the line but be tied
into my kitchens video still on YouTube
where I go but I go siding there's a
light into the zeitgeist enough that
it'll actually a you might predict
something like we ran Bill Clinton screw
it I'm running for president and right
the week of South Carolina though it was
written before that it just you could
feel it happening and so something like
that will last for a while when george w
bush do i say this is i said in this is
presence and i ask forgiveness but there
are some shows that i think now people
love to show they get the joke not
because it's funny yes they say so that
all jon stewart has to do is say bush's
IQ and make a face that everyone knows
to laugh because that must be funny
right but the joke is not in fact being
made no information is has been produced
know why your background or backstory is
required it's a love line they might as
well have a laugh track as do that um
well I'm not there anymore so I'm gonna
comment but there is a term called
collector which I think is real and it's
when people hear something it's exactly
what you're saying they go and they clap
like seals and it doesn't evoke
out loud laughter hilarity like some of
the tapes we've seen but if there's a
recognition of you understand the
apocrypha you're being shown but there
also is the thing and I feel what Chris
is saying is an important thing because
exactly what you're talking about
separates really good satire doing the
homework and pointing out something
satirically or just saying look isn't
bush stupid right I mean and that's
boring I try never to do that I think
that it's not interesting and I think
it's that's a late-night comic monologue
from the bigger
shows it's a Pavlovian cue jazz yeah is
there a bigger rhythm to a political
joke then a regular joke a good one a
good one a good one I think a good
political joke tries to uh you know say
something funny instead of saying
McCain's old Reagan's old you know I
just you know Hillary's whatever you
know what our very not very about her
policy you don't feel better you'll feel
better if you just say nothing but I
think the other thing on it on any joke
and maybe I'll even I'll carefully
differ with my hero over here and say
that any good joke whether it's
political or relationship is they have a
lot of things in common you know they're
communicating something that someone's a
different premise they have to be in
someone's expense serve a really
important purpose gonna have a stick in
that it will let people have discussions
about things that they wouldn't
necessarily you're not gonna go to
mother-in-law and talk about abortion
rights but you might go and talk about
what was on The Daily Show last night or
a hilarious joke about abortion rights
which I was but but new media political
satire I do think is different and
that's to me what's very exciting about
it is obviously SATA has been around
forever and political cartoons you know
hundreds of years ago up to santa live
and everything now but with new media a
couple things I'm noticing one there's
just like conversation around everything
as soon as it happens you put a video on
YouTube and there's 10,000 comments and
they're talking about New York Times so
that kind of like interaction with the
user is really exciting to me the other
thing I'm finding with our videos and
it's almost the opposite of the clap
tour where it's like oh if Jon Stewart
said it and it's about Bush it's got to
be funny you know a lot of our videos
are embedded in blogs people have no
idea that we did it they have no idea
what to expect and a lot of times the
blogs that put them up there don't even
tip off what the joke is like that
Hillary and Bosnia thing most of the
times the blogs talked about it they
would actually just say oh guess what
Hillary actually wasn't lying and just
put the video there so they got to kind
of be in on the joke to a degree and
they weren't you know tipping it off
like Jay Leno or Letterman might on a
late night bit and say hey here's
Hillary in Bosnia and you know exactly
what's coming so the band cable news we
never faked that kind of stuff I say
when it's a joke
if anyone has a question if you dare
take this panel on please step over to
the microphone and we'll get to you so
if you want to get start moseying over
there now please feel free to do so
brave souls out there you brave soul yes
bring it on over there
go ahead line it up my friend woman
where'd he go bring it on will we ever
stop hearing that phrase by the way
apologize furred again today and in
Europe and the first time he pulled us
what he said it was Laura who told him
that was a terrible thing you just said
his wife told uh she's it's interesting
how much impressed she has sir give us
your name where you're probably your
width and who your questions for well my
name is Toni cerise and due to the
nature the question I'll plead the fifth
on who I'm with because it has nothing
to do with where I'm from but I used to
I used to be in radio with Clear Channel
Radio station group and out in Montana
and it was in can't remember if it was
the summer of 2000 or 2001 but every
single news network was talking shark
attacks all summer long
and the total number of shark attacks
that summer had been six with something
like two fatalities how many in Montana
none but what was what was what we had
what we had dug up is we had found that
actually up to that point that year
there had been seven deaths seven deaths
by of people who had been crushed by
vending machines because they lot their
their candy bar didn't come out so they
start shaking that thing and it falls
over on them and and then they're done
are you with there attend a what's that
are you a very ten-day no okay just
jacket and I'm just wondering what you
know with what the mentality is maybe in
in our news media today that just preys
on the on that on that fear factor and
how they all do it can in synchronicity
I love it I love it on the daily show
now when something comes up and they
immediately cut to a montage of every
single news network talking about the
exact same thing using the exact same
talking points bullet points and then
they complain about being fed these
bullet points they're going to use yeah
so how do we get
a from that or can we get away from it
blonds and peril are sexy you get a
blonde in peril you can milk that thing
for a whole wild animal in heaven most
scary most scary words on TV breaking
news yeah all I have to do is point the
camera at some disaster there no work no
research no thought it's brilliant but
not even if there are there are notes
there isn't a school shooting problem in
America there isn't one really Jenny if
the two said it is it's been going down
all the time the the abducted children
on milk cartons fictional satanic child
abuse fictional but always works and
requires no thought no effort just a lot
of innocent people get arrested for
crimes that they haven't committed but
to your specific powerful do your
specific question again defending cable
news tent like they need to be defended
but um there's no pictures of people
getting crushed by the vending machines
why didn't you write Sharkey a weakened
face we could pick that up I saw
pictures of the beach people are knock
I'm sorry
sure I'm there surveillance camera
footage footage and there are
helicopters who travel around the scene
and people are mesmerized how many
people have been mesmerised by a
helicopter going around around watching
it on TV waiting for something to happen
cuz there's nothing else on TV channel
my table how about satellite Oh give me
a couple brochures I will change the
channel yeah I actually would watch
someone pulling a vending machine I mean
that's kind of I'm not so sure about the
shark attacks that's over too quickly I
was and you can't you can't do they
change it's over too fast changing their
giant Li he set it up that was a really
good question the corn everything
everyone's not I do politics I don't do
sharks I'm sorry I was always a friend I
was there for the trend resides
absolutely yeah you know I'm not
dependable hey question who's next shots
cry question who is brave who is brave I
want to while someone gathers their
courage please go ahead walk over here's
my question
well let's go to her first but think
about this ladies and gentlemen this
fall campaign this campaign has been
dominated by new media you start
thinking about so you
tell the audience what's going to happen
this fall that's new that we should look
out for
hi there go ahead I had a question it
something you didn't say how you were
yep my name is Sarah and I work at ABC
News oh I'm in the m.com digital portion
as well so the question that we have
that my friends and I have been talking
about in and outside the office and the
question is what are the perils when
candidates kind of reach a rock star
celebrity status because I think one of
the things that we love about
celebrities today is that we love to
watch the rise but we also love to watch
the ball and what are the parallels of
that and what happens when you know Bon
Jovi right or Britney rises and falls I
mean Britney's not taking away your
health care or giving you health care so
how did that how does that parallel at
all and well what's is now that the
media is gonna focus on you know I mean
I guess I would ask so often you know I
wasn't at the Howard Dean defining
moment screaming but you talk you could
watch it on cable I did over and over
thanks to you welcome and but those who
were in the room said that it didn't
seem as big as life as a way the media
portrayed it I don't know what it's like
reliving Richard Nixon's debate come on
get in the modern media get a TV look at
it it was committed but you know what
there's a difference true but that's all
things that politics is about media it's
how you appear on TV it's amazing or
anyone messes up it's defined by the
media it's a giant mess up and that's
the fall the bottom line is you
shouldn't fall in love with politician
to the politician yeah how do what they
are you think you know it's like how
much you built like how much um sort of
publicly way you've kind of banked up
you know how much it's the the fourth
heart attack it's like how much are
people willing to forgive before it sort
of changes what it means and and how
people are going to respond to it
Christopher well it's a matter of
whether you want charisma in a
politician or not whether it should be
just what the Constitution says it is
but any citizen can do it you need only
average integrity you see you pick up
the garbage you defend the frontiers of
the country you take care that laws are
faithfully executed and you don't try
and be a star of any other kind that
that should be nice would be people
think no I want I'm looking for love in
all the wrong places I I want a
politician who I can adore
who loves me or cares about me and
that's that can be very dangerous
because that's the origin of gemology
which is the origin of totalitarianism
it means somewhat someone is going to
one day promise you a lot a great deal
in exchange for something rather
sinister there's something very
frightening about somebody who actually
would like jobs like that anyway because
it goes very much to your point where
it's like they sat down they looked at
themselves and they said do you know
what's wrong with the world I'm not in
charge and that's lately bizarre so wait
a minute you don't like the cable
networks right you don't like the web
videos and now you're blaming the
candidates let's say audios though I
like I don't know Ben you don't like
sharks I didn't say I said I didn't okay
first you didn't like Hillary's idiots
on cable news anything you need thanks I
couldn't say send in your blog yelling
over me are you trying what are you
saying yapping Ming Ming Ming me you
were training against your moderator
in-house okay please come back to me
I'll just I would I will do is I never
get in a fight with event a get back to
your question um which is your you see
it happening already I mean a to be
successful we built a culture I'm gonna
be a little serious I'm sorry
we're like celebrity gets you places and
we like that and we like that they're
distant from us and that they're special
they eat places we could never afford
and vacation in places we could never
get to but we also love when they owed e
and have a thousand kids out of wedlock
and crash their cars driving cocaine you
know with cocaine spilling in their laps
so this will happen like the beautiful
thing is that you can guarantee and you
already saw the Reverend right thing was
a great like test run for Obama because
there was a lot of like positive stuff
and then all the sudden was like do you
love America why aren't you wearing your
flag are you really a Muslim like
where'd that come from I thought he was
like the super Jesus guy and now like
you're questioning if he's American so
that it'll keep coming back around we we
push them up we bring him down and
questioning it is a Muslim afraid your
problem yeah no need to not in that case
during that case yet everyone lining up
to suck on him and he had to do that he
brought it all on himself none of that
was imposed
Reverend Wright he decided to go to that
church he got married there he had his
children baptized that he gave money to
that thought but he stepped away to all
of it and the and when he and when he
was asked to announce that he said well
it seems like the guy doesn't care
enough about my campaign
so I'll disown him no none of this was
done by us to him
everyone in the press wished it hadn't
happened they still do that still do I
think and that's why that's why the
uncoachable forgettable nothing for the
Delphia speech is still considered to be
one of the greatest addresses by any
politician ever made and everyone here
has yet quoted two words from it I just
want to add we'll wait nor will they
ever we're wrapping up go ahead Ben I
just want to say it seems like it kind
of ties it into the political satire
thing that a lot of times people like to
find one thing to hone in on the
candidate and that's their thing and I
remember reading the Clinton they
actually really liked that they ate a
lot of fries was the thing that people
picked on because people weren't going
to not vote for him for that but the Al
Gore being boring or the Hillary Clinton
being controlling or felt like it was
inevitable you know when when political
satire kind of like hones in on one
subject about Purse about a person I
feel like sometimes that is what kind of
starts what you're saying the backlash
and then all of a sudden and I talked to
one comedian who was saying that they
don't know what you know what what's
going to be the thing that people make
fun of about Obama I don't really know
if I've seen it yet but that you know
part of the thing I think we were making
fun of in the crush on Obama video was
this idea of him as kind of a pop star
but there's gonna be plenty he's
appalled again no there will be but my
point is I guess it seems like all of a
sudden like I didn't know Al Gore was
boring until all the sudden Santa Claus
started hitting that over the head and
also I was like I guess he's boring and
you know you asked the question before
about it wouldn't him I wouldn't ya what
well yeah wouldn't everything and you
asked the question before about like do
we're gonna be good competitors I mean I
for me when we create videos I think
we're like this would be amazing if the
onion the Daily Show somebody they saw
and liked it like it's the opposite on
our and when we to start a year ago but
I'm like honored to be on the stage with
this group and for to a degree I think
part of that reason is I never felt like
the Daily Show or the onion like
pigeon-holed one person and just beat
him over the head for that one plate and
they and they found like that day story
and found something really original
innovative about that story to key in on
and I always had so much
for that and that's what I hope you know
we can do a little bit well I mean yeah
I mean I hope that in doing that and
doing the new project I'm doing now to
me political satire it's just it's weird
it's we have a different mindset than
the onion you guys are amazing
i I just rely on urgency I really like
to be able to see that something
breaking news do it
yes breaking yes all the bells and
whistles breaking news is very well like
watching more like watching uh arteries
huntin are watching arteries are the
only urgency thing it is we've talked a
little bit backstage about this we have
a different challenge at the ending but
we were sliding up that's again we we
did a breaking news mobile text alert
when Hillary dropped out and said Oh
Senator Hillary Clinton has ended bid
for president despite having won already
in February 2007 right and that goes out
to a whole bunch of people and we have
other things that are kind of you know
newspapers right obits well before
people die are just a half loan file so
there's certain things there and we're
with the website and with doing things
online we're also adding new things have
a Google map we're actually at Google
and you're plotting the campaign stops
you should really make a journalism
handbook so everyone here could follow
all your policies I want to thank
everyone in the panel if you helped me
thank you great job and next time we'll
tell you all about the future of the
Internet right thanks for you yeah we
didn't get to that that's right we can
winner here thanks very much for joining
us today folks if you can please join us
for a drink up on the roof just go to
the elevators and folks will escort you
up there again thanks for coming